Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Entrons directement dans votre cerveau
et commençons par
une expérience de pensée.
Partons à Paris, tiens.
Fort de votre courage inébranlable,
vous décidez de vous attaquer
à la butte Montmartre.
Vous y allez, vous montez
les marches quatre à quatre.
Fatigué par cette ascension fulgurante,
vous vous laissez ensuite [envahir]
par les émotions.
Vous êtes arrivé sur la place du Tertre,
lieu bouillonnant
de richesses artistiques.
Qu’il vente ou qu’il neige,
vous y trouverez toujours
d’inconditionnels passionnés,
toujours prêts à partager leur art.
Sur votre droite, derrière son chevalet,
un artiste ressemblant étrangement
à Einstein vous sourit d’un air malicieux.
Ses coups de pinceaux, à première vue
anarchiques et sans aucune logique,
révèlent d’un coup une œuvre incroyable.
Voyant votre intérêt,
il vous propose alors trois manières
différentes de réaliser votre portrait.
La première est une photographie
noir et blanc,
la deuxième, un dessin caricatural
et la troisième, une peinture librement
imaginée par ses soins.
Pour ces trois œuvres,
il vous demande carte blanche,
vous assurant de magnifier votre image.
Laquelle seriez-vous prêt à rapporter chez
vous triomphalement dans votre salon ?
Et si je vous suggérais plutôt de prendre
son miroir, oui, là posé à ses pieds ?
Certains l’avaient vu, je suis sûr, non ?
Maintenant, vous allez me demander :
« Pourquoi ? »
Eh bien, je me suis rappelé
les propos de Picasso :
« Qui voit la figure humaine
correctement ?
Le photographe, le miroir
ou le peintre ? »
Malgré toutes les qualités artistiques
de ce professionnel,
seul le miroir est capable de refléter
une image telle que vous êtes
sans aucune interprétation.
Cette capacité d'objectivité totale
rend cet objet unique.
Il existe encore peu de choses comparables
qui permettent cette fidèle réflexion.
Mais heureusement, rassurez-vous,
un nouveau miroir a vu le jour.
Il nous vient des nouvelles technologies
et c’est... c’est...
roulements de tambour...
l’intelligence artificielle - ou IA.
L’IA, rapidement,
c’est un ensemble de techniques
permettant à un programme
de simuler certains traits
de l’intelligence humaine,
comme le raisonnement ou l'apprentissage.
On développe des algorithmes afin de
rendre notamment ces programmes autonomes.
Autonome, OK, je suis d’accord,
ça peut faire peur,
surtout si on a en tête
Skynet dans Terminator.
Skynet, on la connaît tous.
C’est cette IA contrôlant
la défense nucléaire américaine
et qui se retourne contre l’humanité
en provoquant le jugement dernier.
Oui, rien que ça, l'apocalypse.
Bien entendu, c’est de la fiction
et nous ne sommes pas du tout
capables de créer de tels programmes.
La plupart du temps,
ils apprennent une tâche précise
grâce à des données qu'on leur fournit.
Si vous étiez vous-même un miroir,
vous verriez que je m’appelle Julien,
que je suis data scientist freelance
et que c’est dans le domaine de l’IA
que j’ai trouvé une véritable passion.
Avant cela, j’ai fait des mathématiques,
du développement logiciel
et, plus récemment,
de la business intelligence.
Mais malgré ces casquettes
très techniques,
j’ai décidé d’utiliser
la capacité réflexive de l’IA
pour réaliser des projets
œuvrant pour le vivant,
œuvrant pour nous permettre
de faire mieux.
Mais avant cela, allons explorer un
domaine incontournable de l’IA moderne :
les réseaux de neurones artificiels qui
imitent le comportement de nos cerveaux.
Ça, ce sont les neurones.
Chaque neurone est lié
au précédent et au suivant.
On souhaite apprendre à ce réseau
la reconnaissance d’un arbre.
Prenons un saule pleureur, par exemple.
Eh bien, chaque pixel de cette image
est envoyé à travers le réseau
et chaque neurone effectue des calculs
avec les données qu’il reçoit.
Le dernier neurone nous dit si oui ou non,
il reconnaît un saule pleureur,
le but étant de minimiser son erreur.
En fonction de sa réponse,
on va remonter le réseau
pour renforcer les connexions
qui ont permis un bon résultat
et affaiblir celles qui n’ont pas réussi.
Et on recommence
sur des dizaines de milliers d’exemples
jusqu’à ce que le réseau soit correctement
ajusté pour reconnaître cet arbre.
En réalité, la reconnaissance
d’image nécessite
des réseaux bien plus complexes que cela.
C’est tout naturellement que je me suis
ainsi orienté vers le deep learning
ou apprentissage profond.
C’est une technique en IA
qui permet à la machine
d’apprendre par elle-même.
Eh oui, c’est possible.
Son fonctionnement est similaire
à ce qu’on vient de voir avec l’arbre,
mais il permet de créer
des réseaux gigantesques
de plusieurs milliers de neurones,
ce qui permet de traiter
des sujets très complexes.
Maintenant, projetez-vous :
imaginez que vous vouliez apprendre
un texte de Shakespeare par cœur.
Si, si, essayez quand même :
« Être ou ne pas être. »
À chaque paragraphe appris correctement,
je vais vous donner une récompense.
Du chocolat pour monsieur,
du saucisson pour madame,
un navet au premier rang, si vous voulez.
Plus vous allez progresser
dans l’apprentissage du texte,
plus vous allez chercher
à profiter de ces plaisirs.
Eh bien, nous pouvons faire exactement
la même chose avec un algorithme.
Cette technique est appelée
apprentissage par renforcement
et elle a déjà été déployée
dans beaucoup de domaines
comme la téléphonie, l’automobile,
la médecine ou l’astronomie.
D’ailleurs, l’astronomie nous apprend
que nous ne sommes qu’un grain
de sable dans cet immense univers.
Cela devrait nous amener
à une humilité universelle, non ?
Notre évolution nous a permis
de développer
une certaine forme d’intelligence,
mais nous restons des êtres vivants
parmi tant d’autres.
C’est notre Terre et tout ce qui s’y
trouve qui est unique, pas nous.
Il est indispensable de la préserver
pour pouvoir y vivre paisiblement.
C’est en reprenant conscience
de cette place parmi les vivants
que nous pourrons progresser,
et notamment à travers
le développement durable.
C’est ainsi que j’ai décidé d’apporter
la force et l’impulsion de l’IA
au service de ce domaine.
Concrètement, un agriculteur souhaite par
exemple diminuer ses consommations d’eau.
Grâce à une série de capteurs
et de données météorologiques,
nous pourrons développer un algorithme
pour le guider dans ses choix
pour une consommation raisonnée.
Mais inversement, on peut appliquer
à tout projet d’IA
les trois piliers
du développement durable :
social, économique et environnemental.
À la manière du yin et du yang,
toute chose à son pendant
pour se compléter et s’équilibrer.
En amenant ces valeurs
du développement durable,
il est possible d’entrevoir
de nouvelles perspectives,
de donner à l’IA une autre représentation
que Skynet qui veut tous nous tuer :
une IA au service du vivant.
En relocalisant nos projets,
en utilisant beaucoup moins de données,
en reconnaissant l’autre
dans son altérité,
pour une société plus tolérante.
Les enjeux sociétaux sont chamboulés
par la crise de la Covid-19
que nous sommes en train de vivre.
La relocalisation de nos activités
est un défi majeur,
tant sur le plan social
qu’économique ou environnemental.
Je parlais tout à l’heure
de saucisson ou de chocolat,
mais on pourrait rajouter
les fruits et les légumes.
Ne pourrait-on pas optimiser
leurs environnements de production
pour favoriser la consommation
de produits locaux ?
J’ai ainsi pris le pari d’utiliser
ce système par renforcement,
similaire au fonctionnement
de la dopamine.
Il pourrait permettre une aide
aux décisions des élus locaux
pour favoriser le développement
des circuits courts.
Ce projet se nomme AALIA :
« AAL » pour
« autonomie alimentaire locale »
et « IA » -
vous devez savoir maintenant pourquoi.
L’autonomie alimentaire,
c’est la capacité d’un territoire
à être autonome
dans un secteur de son alimentation.
Prenons l’exemple de Blois.
Je me réjouissais à l’idée de venir,
sachant que Blois est principalement
autonome par... son vin.
Non ?
Plus sérieusement, l’autonomie alimentaire
de Blois dans les légumes, par exemple,
était de 4,4 % en 2017.
Qu’est-ce que ça signifie ?
Sur la consommation totale de légumes
dans n’importe quel produit alimentaire,
seuls 4,4 % ont été produits
par Blois ou sa périphérie.
Donc plus de 95 % proviennent d’ailleurs.
Le projet AALIA tente
de répondre à ce problème
en proposant d’optimiser et de prédire
une évolution
des productions agricoles locales.
Mais concrètement, comment ça marche ?
J’ai récolté un maximum de données,
notamment mises à disposition
par les organismes publics
comme les importations et exportations,
les données de production,
des informations géographiques
et bien entendu,
l’autonomie alimentaire des villes.
De tout cela, j’ai créé
deux modèles d’IA complémentaires.
Un premier utilisant les réseaux
de neurones vus précédemment.
À la manière de l’arbre
et de sa reconnaissance,
ce premier modèle va prédire
l’autonomie alimentaire du département
en fonction de ses indicateurs.
Et un second modèle utilisant
le système par renforcement.
Il va faire varier les données de
production, d’importation, d’exportation,
puis, grâce au premier modèle,
va prédire ce que serait l’autonomie
alimentaire dans ces conditions.
Si l’autonomie alimentaire a augmenté,
tout va bien,
on envoie une récompense.
Non, ce n’est pas un saucisson,
juste un chiffre positif - disons +1.
Si l’autonomie alimentaire
a diminué : pas bien,
on envoie une pénalité, disons -1.
Et on recommence
en programmant le système pour
qu’il cherche à maximiser cette récompense
et ainsi à augmenter
l’autonomie alimentaire.
Cette IA va donc proposer
différents scénarii
pour connaître
les modalités de développement
des productions agricoles locales.
Imaginez l’aide que ça pourrait
être pour nos décideurs locaux.
Si l’algorithme prend en compte
la complexité de la réalité,
alors les choix proposés
ne peuvent être qu’objectifs
par rapport à la réalité du terrain.
Mais - parce que oui, il y a un mais -
pour arriver à cette objectivité totale,
il faut réussir à éviter
ce qu’on appelle les biais.
Un biais, c’est le fait
de biaiser un résultat
et de discriminer, soit des personnes,
ou plus largement, des caractéristiques.
Pour bien comprendre ce que c’est,
allons faire un tour en Bretagne.
On voyage beaucoup aujourd’hui.
En termes d’émissions de CO2 en Bretagne,
il vaut mieux acheter des tomates
cultivées en pleine terre
qui viennent du sud de la France
plutôt que des tomates locales bretonnes
cultivées en serre intensive.
Sauf que si dans l’algorithme,
nous n’incluons pas des données
relatives au mode de production,
il ressortira qu’il vaut mieux développer
les cultures de tomates en Bretagne,
que ce soit sous serre ou non.
C’est ça, un biais.
Selon une étude publiée dans la revue
Global Food Security, en 2018,
seuls 6 % de nos assiettes correspondent
aux émissions de CO2 liées aux transports.
Les 94 % restants concernent
les emballages, les pesticides,
les fertilisants, l’eau ou la nourriture
consommées, la déforestation.
Il faut réellement avoir conscience
de ces biais,
car ils ne proviennent pas de l’IA, non,
ils proviennent de nous,
humains, de nos données,
et surtout de nos manières de faire.
C’est pour cela, selon moi,
que l’IA est une vraie révolution.
Pour la première fois,
nous avons un regard extérieur
qui peut nous renvoyer nos travers.
Alan Turing, figure emblématique
du domaine de l’IA,
le prédisait déjà dans les années 50
en disant :
« Les tentatives de création de machines
pensantes nous seront d’une grande aide
pour découvrir comment
nous pensons nous-mêmes. »
C’est sans doute la toute première
pensée humaniste relative à l’IA.
Alors oui,
certains vont l’utiliser pour fliquer
les gens par la reconnaissance faciale
ou pour accroître ce toujours plus
caractéristique de la société
de consommation.
Mais heureusement, cet humanisme
existe aussi dans ce domaine.
S’il faut retenir un élément essentiel,
c’est que l’IA n’a pas de conscience
ni de libre arbitre.
Elle ne sait pas mettre en perspective
plusieurs valeurs,
puisqu’elle n’est tout simplement pas
dotée d’une conscience.
Je crois en une IA qui a la capacité
d’élaborer des scénarii complexes
et qui puisse servir
de support aux décideurs,
mais où l’humain reste au cœur
de la prise de décision.
Je crois en une réflexion éthique
autour de chaque projet
afin de mesurer
les conséquences de nos actes
dans le respect du droit humain
et dans le respect de l’environnement.
Au lieu de voir dans notre miroir
cette IA malfaisante,
observons cet autre reflet qui nous
rapproche des valeurs humanistes,
essentielles à la pérennité du vivant,
et construisons, amenons
cette force à notre société.
Ce que je voudrais voir dans ce miroir,
c'est une prise de conscience collective
de la nécessité d'une consommation
locale et raisonnée.
Ce que je voudrais y voir,
c’est l’humanité qui s’unit
autour du développement durable
pour que ce monde aux pieds d’argile
devienne plus stable.
Ce que je voudrais y voir,
c’est l’intelligence artificielle
augmenter nos capacités
sans porter atteinte à notre pluralité.
Ce que je voudrais encore y voir,
c’est une nouvelle ère
où chacun puisse, à son niveau,
apporter sa pierre à l’édifice.
Mais au final, ce que je vois
aujourd’hui à travers ce miroir,
c’est cette recherche
des valeurs essentielles
que porteraient également
les technologies nouvelles
pour allier progrès, éthique
et humanisme intemporel.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)